hey what's up y'all i'm kelly clarkson
and this is try that trend on the kelly
clarkson show
it works like this my team will find
something trending on the internet
and i have to try and master it in a
limited amount of time
since we celebrated the magical powers
of a glass of wine as part of our rad
mom hour today
grab your glasses ladies do you have
some oh you have some as well
all right it's let's one to mommy y'all
i'm going to try a very special tick
tock challenge
apparently this is called the hashtag
jeanine a bottle challenge and here is
everything i need
a phone a wine glass and a bottle of red
wine
so i love that let's take a look
[Music]
oh i see what you did there oh she
picked her leg up oh this is gonna take
ability
oh she just [ __ ] okay i'm a genie to
bottle let's see this one wait
oh with her sexy point of the toe
boop oh that's so clever okay
okay okay i'm gonna try this here we go
let's do it okay
record is it recording okay here we go
i love that i'm doing it in a skirt and
everybody else is in yoga pants
okay here we go don't break your ankle
okay here we go
oh wait i'm screwed i have a skirt on so
we're gonna have to hold it here we go
here we go here we go
okay wait i have to hold it okay
do not fall okay
[Music]
baby
[Applause]
no wait this will be the best part
i approve this message
you